I hear that exam season and starting up
in India so for my Indian viewers who
may already be well-acquainted with the
exam I'm going to show today hopefully
this video may save you a quick revision
of some of the topics that are involved
and a reminder of what's in the syllabus
and what you're expected to know for my
viewers who are not in India let this
video be a quick glimpse into what our
Indian friends have to go through today
I'm going to be looking at the je e main
exam now I've covered the je e advanced
exam before on my channel so I guess
this is winding back a step to the main
exam which is used as an entrance exam
into some of India's colleges this exam
here is paper number one from 2018 I
believe that in 2019 the exams are going
to be held online you're not going to be
able to have a calculator and there's
over a million candidates it's at this
exam I do also believe that the syllabus
doesn't change from year to year so
hopefully the questions that we look at
today and the topics that are involved
are still going to be relevant into the
future I'm really just going to talk
about the physics section in this video
because physics is my area there is also
math and chemistry components to this
exam but let's first just have a look at
the physics section you get three hours
to do the entire exam so that's probably
one hour per section and I've made a few
notes on these physics problems whether
it's formula or basic ideas that you're
going to need to know to get started
solving the problem but I obviously
haven't written down everything that
you're going to need to solve them and
there's no time in this video to solve
every question but let's just have a
look at what components of the syllabus
each question covers so we're starting
off with a question about energy and
momentum specifically about collisions
this question uses the idea of
conservation of momentum then we go on
to heat and thermodynamics and a
question about the kinetic theory of
gases here you're working with the
change in momentum and with
pressure question three we're dealing
with properties of matter in terms of
elasticity and I've written down here
the formula for the bulk modulus which
is what you're going to need to get
started here
also you're going to need a relationship
between volume and radius number four is
about DC Circuit's and about working out
an equivalent resistance and voltage
question five is about energy and
momentum including potential energy so
I've written down a few formulas here
like centripetal force and working out
total energy from potential and kinetic
number six we're dealing with the
dynamics questions so we've got we need
to know concepts about friction so
there's one little formula I've put here
and it's a pulley system so knowing the
threshold of force which is related to
the coefficient of friction and the
normal force going on to question seven
we're dealing with
I guess modern physics as it's still
classed on the syllabus and dealing with
atoms I think we're probably going to
need to do some manipulation of the
Rydberg equation here so I've got that
written there
number eight is waves and optics so
dealing with polarizing filters
Christian nine another problem about
modern physics and atoms you're going to
need to in this Christian use the
binomial expansion because you're
dealing with large values of n we've
then got a question about semiconductors
or diodes and essentially for this
question I was surprised that you need
to have memorized or know that a silicon
diode is taking a voltage of 0.7 volts
when used in the Fords direction other
than knowing that you need to use I
equals V over R to work out number 10
question 11 is about magnetism and the
force on a moving charge so it's useful
to know this equation here which is to
do with working out the radius of an
orbit a circular orbit of a charge which
has a force opponent number 12 is about
capacitors and dielectrics so having
some relation between dielectrics and
the total charge which is stored number
13 this time we have an A
see circuit and you need to know
something about what's called a quality
factor for question 14 it's about
communication systems and bandwidth so
they're asking us about the number of
telephonic channels and that would be
given by the total bandwidth over the
channel bandwidth of each channel so
that gives us our answer out there
number 15 is to do with waves and
resonance so it's useful to be able to
relate some of the basic properties of
waves like speed and wavelength to some
slightly harder concepts like the
young's modulus here number 16 is quite
a tricky question i think about moments
of inertia and to do with a rotating
object so i guess really needing to
skill up on how to find moments of
inertia for what is a semi complicated
shape even though it is symmetrical you
also for this one i think it's useful to
know the parallel axis theorem and use
it along this axis here number 17 is
about what's called electrostatics so
probably useful to know how to find the
potential of a point charge at any
radius away from it number 18 is another
one about DC Circuit's this time it's
about something called a potentiometer i
not really that confident with those but
hopefully maybe you've done a few
practices with one of those i think in
the end it comes down to comparing the
cases that it gives you number 19 is
about electromagnetic waves and the
speed of a wave number 20 is about waves
- but this is about like waves and
optics and it's talking about single
slit diffraction which is useful to know
the angular width of a central maximum
in single slit diffraction which is us
here and it's also talking about young's
double slit experiments so similarly we
have a little bit of help here we can
remember some of these formulas number
21 we're looking at simple harmonic
motion a classic in physics so hopefully
you've got a bit of practice with that
number 22 is about rotation and again
moments of inertia i often find these
moments of inertia questions a bit
tricky number 23 is about energy and
momentum
we have a collision and again one of the
fundamental concepts will be that
momentum is conserved as there are no
external forces acting here number 24 is
about magnetism and we've got our
classic formula here for finding the
strength of the magnetic field 25 this
one is actually to do with like
uncertainty and percentage error it's
also relating to density though so
you're going to need to know density as
well as how to deal with errors 26 this
is another one on DC Circuit's and it
will come down to setting up some
simultaneous equations so to go about
that really just write out everything
you know and see if you can make enough
equations out of that to solve for how
many variables you have number 27 we've
got an AC circuit and 28 they've given
us a few graphs here they want us to
find the incorrect one and it's to do
with just looking at them carefully
reading the axes and knowing your
kinematics nearly at the end last page
with questions here 29 we have
thermodynamics and this I believe would
be about the first law of thermodynamics
so some useful things like that you'll
need to get started knowing what our
gamma factor is and knowing some of
these equations here like the change in
internal energy and the temperature
number 30
our last physics question and this one
is about circular motion so finding a
relation between a few different
variables and seeing what are
proportional it then goes on to the math
section but like I said to keep this
video from being too long I won't go
through that in detail we can have a
little flick through it's I guess just
as long as the physics section and then
we also go on to chemistry you can see
the diagrams coming in here so that's a
little glimpse at what the syllabus is
like if you're doing an exam here in
India if you're doing je emails the
questions like that I've written in the
margins by no means all you're going to
need to know to solve it some of these
are quite involved some of them are
really true
yeah like I said these were just some of
my own notes that I would want to keep
in mind especially if I was thinking
about what I had to memorize and what I
needed to get started on some of these
questions looking back at some of the
stuff I'm grateful that I've finished my
physics degree and so I don't have to
stress about taking these exams anymore
I'm just looking at them for fun now I
know that it can be extremely stressful
if you're not in my shoes and you're
actually you know really stressed about
having to perform well on something like
this so all I can really say is good
luck to you I hope that throughout
studying you managed to stay healthy and
happy as well and see that at the end of
the exam there is a reward and there is
I guess light at the end of the tunnel
it's really an opportunity to try and
show what you know sometimes you won't
do as well as you hope to but I hope
that for you other opportunities come up
maybe after the exams and that you do
end up doing something you really enjoy
thank you for watching this I hope you
learned something or that maybe it was
helpful and I'll see you next time
you